today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink is comm slash David
Pakman I put the link right below this
video you all probably know by now that
when channels like mine shows like mine
talk about stories like the one I'm
about to talk about we get demonetized
and penalized on YouTube and Facebook
but what has been captured on video over
the last 24 to 48 hours is two insane
and it's too important not to tell you
about it and to show it to you so let's
dig right into it first of all a New
York Police Department officers have
been caught on video beating a cyclist
with batons as he tries to cross the
street the cyclist seems to be crossing
his bike while wearing a helmet at a
crosswalk mind you not even jaywalking
and multiple officers are just beating
the crap out of him and it looks like
they're beating the cyclist on the upper
leg eventually the cyclist is forced off
of his bike bike before the video ends
we don't know exactly what led up to it
but at this point in the video this is
not an individual that is resisting and
there are multiple officers beating him
with batons and this led to
congresswoman Alexandria Cassio Cortes
to tweet quote horrifying you start with
the tiny possibility that two officers
may be walking over to de-escalate the
abuse of one instead they join in
beating a man trying to get out of
traffic this isn't a problem of bad
apples or incidents this is an
institutional and systemic crisis and
the reason I'm picking this incident to
talk about is that congresswoman AOC s
response mirrors exactly what I've been
talking about all week when she says
this isn't a problem of bad apples or
incidents this is an institutional and
systemic crisis when I did my first
commentary about the protests and the
civil unrest that we're experiencing on
the Monday show that was the main point
that I tried to make the there were
really two points point one was
anybody claiming some grand unifying
theory about this this is all about
capitalism this is all about race this
is all about police brutality it's not
so any grand unifying theory that
focuses on on one element is destined to
be to fall short but maybe most
importantly that the individual
incidents may give us a window into the
systemic problems a lens a suggestion
but really we need to be talking about
the systemic aspects that are plaguing
our country and the debate over good and
bad police doesn't actually address the
systemic issues that are at the heart of
much of what is going on in another
video from North Carolina police
likewise were filmed in this video they
are destroying elements of medical for
lack of a better term a sort of medical
station that had some medics and basic
first-aid supplies and a lot of bottled
water you can see in this video police
standing above a ton of destroyed and
poured out bottled water there in
Asheville North Carolina a report said
that police hit some of the medics with
their shields and knocked people to the
ground and this is again you know we can
talk about individuals but there's
something particularly nefarious in this
instance because of the principle called
medical neutrality so um we have norms
that are being ignored we've talked
about you don't go after press and we've
seen press attacked both by some
protesters and by police in different
places over the last week but now we're
talking about the principle of medical
neutrality in any conflict you do not go
after anybody who is providing medical
services you have a protest you have
police most protesters are peaceful most
police are good there's some scuffle you
do not pull the medical people into it
police may try to argue well you know if
the medical people weren't there the
protesters would be less brazen and
aggressive no at the international level
going after the the medical going after
medical
is a violation of the Geneva Convention
these are of course domestic protests
we're talking about domestic law
enforcement the Geneva Conventions don't
apply but if this conflict instead of
being between protesters and looters or
police and protesters or police and
looters or whatever if this were a
conflict between two countries and the
Geneva Convention rules applied either
side destroying medical elements would
be a violation of the Geneva Convention
so we've got attacks on media people
from the press hit with rubber bullets
sprayed hit with shields almost
everything we've seen over the last
seven days the point of this segment is
not let's pick on police or particular
police any more than I pick on
individual protesters most protesters
are peaceful protesters are peaceful the
ones that aren't peaceful are really not
protesters they're doing other things
they're looters they're instigators
insiders whatever provocateurs police
are mostly doing the right thing and we
have shows of support and kneeling and
and singing and everything with police
from all over the country but this is
about the bigger picture we have a
horrible situation going on much of it
because of protests because of police
brutality and we are seeing everything
from cyclists beaten to a medical
station destroyed to a president saying
hey here's an idea for how to solve the
protests and unrest caused by police
brutality let's encourage more brutality
against protesters everything we are
seeing at a systemic level is the
opposite of what we need thankfully at
the individual level many police
departments have been great many
individual officers have been great
we've seen protesters bringing water to
police we've seen police joining
protesters and all of this stuff but
unless the systems are changed nothing
will change and so later on today a lot
of people on my streams this week and
via email have been saying David can you
explain how to deal with police
brutality and essentially none of it has
to do with the individual it is all
systemic changes and I'm going to
outline them for you a little bit later
on in the program okay we're going to
have more about this next topic
next week so I don't want to spend a ton
of time on it but I think given the
events of the last seven days it bears
mention if we've learned anything over
the last seven days
yes we've confirmed that Donald Trump
can't lead but we knew that but we've
also gotten reinforcement that Donald
Trump is not going to go peacefully if
he loses to Joe Biden in November now
I've said before this is not some
ominous conspiracy theory where Donald
Trump will be able to stay in power
indefinitely like a king I continue to
believe that if Donald Trump loses in
November he will leave you will leave
eventually but he's going to do it under
protest and it's not going to be what we
traditionally think of as a peaceful
transition of power remember he won in
2016 and has been arguing that it was
rigged against him okay he won and has
spent three years saying the results
can't be trusted Yale forensic
psychiatrist dr. bandy Lee is now
warning that the shows of strength and
really the shows of false strength false
displays of strength from Donald Trump
over the last week foreshadow his likely
behavior if he loses the 2020 election
so when we say false displays of
strength we mean the Bible photo-op the
tweets and statements about sending in
the military his obvious lie that he
didn't go to the bunker for protection
on Friday he went to inspect the bunker
give me a break dude the idea is that
all of these completely transparent
shows of supposed strength are Trump
laying the framework for continuing to
build a legitimate power so that later
in five months
he will question the results of the
election here's another example blaming
the protests on an Tifa in order to try
to disqualify the overwhelmingly
peaceful protesters and they're
completely respectable and and real
motives for protesting so it's
interesting to see a psychiatrist put a
name to it but the reaction from anybody
who's been paying attention is well yeah
Trump has been laying the groundwork to
complain about the upcoming election
results for a long time Democrats can
only win if they cheat that's another
one that Trump has been using off and on
for the last year
Trump has slowly been ratcheting up the
authoritarianism culminating so far
Monday with his threat to send in the
military against the demands of
governor's even these little
authoritarian slides tighten his grip a
tiny bit his priority has always been
personal power and we have to be
prepared for him to challenge the
results in November and this is not
about martial law this is not about
suspending elections and declaring
himself King I believe he will go but we
have to ensure that our institutions are
actually prepared to remove him when it
happens and it may not even you know
even remove suggests someone's going to
show up by force and remove Trump it's
more that our institutions just have to
make it abundantly clear that if his
term is ending his term is ending and if
he's not reelect 'add someone else is
coming in and that's it and it I still
don't believe that there's gonna be any
removal by force and I don't want to be
a broken record but he won and
questioned the results he won and
questioned the results in November of
2016 just imagine what will happen if he
loses let me know what you expect in
November on Twitter where you can find
me at D Pakman you can also get the
daily audio podcast of the show for free
on your favorite podcasting app whether
it's iTunes Spotify Pandora Google Play
podcasts stitcher really whatever you
want get the podcast let me know your
thoughts about Trump and November on
Twitter at D Pakman we have a packed
show in store for you today the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blink Asst
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash David Pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are suzanne adams and keith wall
thanks to both of you for supporting the
show with a membership also thanks to
Brandon long car who's today's longtime
sustaining member of the day Brandon's
been a member for almost 5 years an
incredible amount of time join these
great people by grabbing a membership at
join pakman.com ok let's go to the phone
lines at six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty and see what is on
people's minds starting with our caller
from the six seven eight caller from the
six seven eight area code what's your
name where are you calling from
yes I can okay sorry I I'm having a hard
time hearing you said are there protests
where I'm living yeah yeah there's
there's been protests protests in Boston
both in the downtown areas in the Forest
Hills area which is a little bit outside
of the city in Brockton which is really
not Boston it's the Boston area there's
been a bunch of protests yeah my main
question is I see mostly the young
people standing up for you know people
like George Boyd and yet the boomers
tend to look they always been decide to
please no matter what they do why is it
that boomers they always look down upon
us forever questioning the status quo
when they were the ones during Vietnam
protesting the status quo what changed
with them that made them so status quo
ish that's interesting well so there's
two parts I mean part one is once you
live with a system for a while and you
feel that the system sort of works for
you you're less likely to demand that
the system be radically changed you you
with me sort of on that part at least to
start with yeah now I guess the other
thing so in terms of the pro
tests there is no doubt that the people
protesting are disproportionately
younger folks I don't know that that's
hugely surprising it seems to me that at
every era it is overwhelmingly people
between 20 and 40 20 and 45 that are
doing the protesting and I think it's
just by that I think I don't know that
that's unique to this situation when you
look at the ages of arrests it's been
mostly like 18 to 35 year olds I don't
know that that means older folks aren't
if you look at the polling it seems the
country is pretty United on on the Floyd
Fiasco all right I just had you know
like I include what my mother who think
if it doesn't involve them my mother
only my mother my own mother things day
if it doesn't involve her and her her
kids and grandkids she shouldn't get
involved I just don't understand how
people can just be so blind
well unfortunately it is not uncommon
that a lot of folks don't really care
much about an issue or consider it
seriously until it affects them look at
all these Republican Congressmen who are
anti-gay their whole lives then their
kid I knew is gay and they're like you
know what I've seen the light now we
need to do this we need to do that
that's a sad reality about humanity that
you stumbled across I don't think it's
unique to your mom yeah yeah that's just
like um Bill Maher called it the empathy
gap but hey I'm gonna let you go thank
you for answering my question that
actually makes a lot of sense thank you
all right thank you my friend great to
hear from you thank you so much let's go
to uh oh let's go to dontel in Florida
dontel in Florida what's going on dontel
hey David um say that you've been doing
I like I appreciate that you can do what
you can to like provided new ones take
to all the protests of what's going on
right now thank you
and so I have two topics about these
protests that I want to talk about the
first is the stunning display of
gratuitous violence and lawlessness
complete officers in police departments
across the country mm-hmm ironic we as
people are protesting police brutality
right and in fact is even worse than
that dontel dontel please do me the
favor of keeping the phone just a little
further from your mouth that the the
mouthpiece because you're you're coming
in hot and we can't control it on our
end too well right now it's not it's
actually there's an even crazier
hypocrisy which is all of this is was
catalyzed by police brutality and the
president came out and said I think the
governor's need to be more brutal in
their responses which could not be more
backwards so yes agree with you spot-on
with a with the first part go ahead and
so these are people who are their job
they are trying to maintain the peace
yes and what we're seeing is they're
doing the exact opposite they're the
ones who are initiating the violence the
overwhelming majority of time at these
peaceful protests so and a lot of times
when we see these videos normally when
we see videos of police brutality a lot
of people in this country on the left
and on the right they say that those are
just the bad apples
the overwhelming majority of the police
they're good they're law-abiding and all
of that yeah but all of that what up and
smoke over the last few days with the
entire police departments at police
precincts mobilized to violently break
up lawful protest and the good police
officers the law-abiding police officers
they didn't intervene and they didn't do
anything while the other police officers
were assaulting protesters which is
illegal and it could be arrested for by
the way yeah and think about yeah yeah
so what do you think about the idea of
the police officers who've been on video
assaulting protesters and unlawfully
breaking a constitutional protected
protest what do you think about them
being arrested and prosecuted yeah so I
hope that they are I mean I hope every
Internal Affairs and this I'm gonna have
a segment actually coming up later on
the show today where I'm going to talk
about exactly how police training should
be totally restructured but we I hope
that these videos that are spreading
like wildfire are actually turned over
and looked at by police internal
investigation departments
my understanding is that there have been
some officers caught on tape who already
are now entering the discipline process
you know we'll have to follow to see if
anything actually comes of it but I'm
completely with you and in fact I
tweeted a couple of days ago are we
building a list of names are we
identifying the people that are so
brutally going you know going after even
press like people who are just there
reporting on what's going on they should
all we got we've got to be taking names
and and going after all of the ones that
have broken the law and so the top one
is talk about is the moving so yes there
are people who are opportunistic and
they aren't really involved in the
Georgia Florida protests right and they
see this as an opportunity to take
advantage of the situation
yes that's true yep but if there are
also people who are involved in the
protests who are engaged in looting - so
the what for me it all comes back to the
question of would people be rioting will
people be looting if they were
financially financially secure because
people are forgetting we are in the
middle of economic depression 40 million
people have lost their jobs 40 percent
of small businesses might be permanently
closed in the next couple months right
thousands of landlords right now are in
court filing eviction for eviction so
that as soon as the temporary bans are
listed in the next couple of days they
can start throwing people out on the
street so and this is and the response
from our government
Democrats and Republicans has been to
ignore the economic depression and we
people hire and drive while they bail
out corporations and the richest people
in the country to the tune of the
trillions of dollars and before all this
even happen we were already dealing with
historic wealth inequality in this
country and the living economic
condition for a lot of people with
desperate so when you add this on top of
course you're gonna get looting so my
suggestion to people if you want to stop
the ruling if you want to limit the
ruining it's not
to show the the the people who are they
doing it it's not
you shouldn't you're not gonna do it by
calling them out if you want them to
stop moving so the way I see the best
way to do it is to have them organized
and and do targeted protest at the
politicians that Congress I think I get
the point
dontel you're coming you're coming in so
distorted that I'm gonna have to let you
go but I basically agree with you
however I wouldn't absolve any
individual looter of the fact that they
are breaking the law but you're
completely right that we can't ignore
the circumstances that lead to people
feeling like they need to loot there's
no question about it I'm with you dontel
on that okay I'm gonna let you go and we
are we thought our phone system was
working perfectly and then dontel was
just coming in so hot gonna have to keep
looking into that let's go next to our
caller from the three one five area code
who's calling today from three one five
yes you are
who's this hi I'm son caller I was just
thinking about how all this is going to
impact the election and impact just
politics going forward over the rest of
the year and beyond I mean the the
current protesters poses the pandemic
you know I would want to believe that
this is going to really be a one-two
punch to trump to the Republicans but I
been concerned about a backlash coming
and as well as and I think even if
Republicans are taken out and Trump's
taken out in the election that they tend
to do better as is an opposition and
they tend to do better campaigning and
having something it has someone to run
against and so I just wonder if any any
good can be made from this if we can get
Democrats and progressives into
positions power to effect change that
it's not going to lead to kind of
somewhere backlash just like after obama
and democrats came in after bush and
then so listen there's a lot of
questions in there let's address at
least a couple of the things you're
mentioning first of all of course
republicans are going to take whoever is
ever in power on the Democratic side
demonize them fundraise by lying about
them come up with the most horrible
allegations and assert of course of
course that's going to happen if we say
well then we'd better not elect anybody
then we're just gonna lose every
election so of course they're going to
do it we need to be better at fighting
them rather than ceding the space and
conceding that to them your first
question was could there be a backlash
and Trump rockets to re-election in
November I think the answer is yes and
this is why I've been urging such
caution you know right now we've got a
disastrous economic situation partially
fueled by a disastrous reaction by Trump
to the pandemic combined with Trump
saying hey let's here's the solution to
protests about police brutality let's
send in the federal military to be even
more brutal like it's crazy Joe Biden is
up 11 in some polls okay I think it is
come you're very right to be skeptical
that this is going to hold through
November if the protests die down it's
very unlikely the protests are gonna
last five months
if coronavirus continues to decline in a
lot of places I mean it's going up in
some places and it's very much down in
some places but if the economy starts to
appear to be recovering you could get a
window of six weeks in late October into
November where Trump gets himself
reelected because people feel like hey
things are getting back on track and so
I think we need to be very careful about
looking at any of these polls that say
Oh Biden's gonna crush him Biden may
crush Trump Biden may lose and we've got
to be really careful about it
right and obviously I I've never been
the type of person that felt like you
shouldn't vote even if you're candidates
and won in the primary yeah and also
that I do believe that Trump does have a
chance of winning so again I want
I want to believe I'm not going to let
myself be lulled into a false sense of
security but I do want to believe that
he's on his way out I think I'm just
very stark from cuz I came of age
politically really when Obama during
Obama's first election and that's when
like my my beliefs
yeah becomes clarify and I think just
the backlash to him how swift it was I
mean I remember it was it's around when
the Tea Party first cropped up but it
was between like February or April 2009
I mean if I recall correctly it was very
soon very soon after he came in and then
it was a 2000 or 2010 midterms I just
think that that's something to I mean
I'm probably getting ahead of myself
yeah listen filler here's what we got to
do let's try to replace Trump with Biden
let's try to take control of the Senate
we've got five six good good races that
could be won and then okay the the
opposition party tends to win in
midterms but maybe this time they don't
and then we fight for the 2022 midterms
we can't win the 2022 midterms this
November we can only win the elections
that are this November this November if
that makes sense
all right my friend I'm gonna let you go
cuz I've got a bunch of people who who
want to get on let me take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we will get right back to the phones
momentarily the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show we are taking
your phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let me pick up on our caller from the 5
5 9 area code who's calling today from 5
5 9 hi David this is John hey John
what's up hey so I was wondering what do
you think the likelihood of the next
president either democratic or
republican you know wherever they may be
with that they would create some sort of
federal agencies oversee police
investigations into like police violence
and misconduct like that and what do you
think the effectiveness of such a agency
could be so I don't know if we need a
federal agency to oversee police I think
it would be really tough to get that
done with police unions being as strong
as they are in the next segment I am
going to give my prescription for
dealing with police violence and I'm
going to talk about databases of sorts I
think that we need two things and I
won't fully go into them because I'm
going to do this next segment number one
there should be a national database of
bad actors in police departments because
right now it is too easy I'm not saying
it's easy but it is too easy for a
police officer to make a deal to leave a
department because of wrongdoing or
complaints but it's done in a way where
there's no place that future police
departments can see this officers
history and they end up rehiring a
problem officer and the the vast
majority of police officers are not the
problem the small percentage that are
often are repeat offenders so
by just eliminating a few of these bad
actors you would dramatically reduce the
number of bad acts so to speak so you
establish a database of police officer
complaints and you require both that a
police department has to report to the
database and a new hiring Police
Department must check the database so
that nobody can get away with saying we
just didn't know so that's one thing the
other thing is I think that we do need a
review system for police shootings and
use of force incidents that includes
civilians where in many cases these
things are reviewed essentially
internally internally by police
sometimes in concert with you know the
DA's office in certain situations I
don't think that that's cutting it I
think we definitely need accountability
to civilians as well so those are a
couple of the things I think we need to
do I think a federal agency to do the
reviewing is going to be a tough sell
yeah I was thinking that the employee
like implicating such a system would
probably if anything just caused a lot
of backlash and you know attention to
the police union and yeah stuff like
that but I had one other quick question
yeah about Trump and his Twitter account
you know he's trying to push forward the
new restrictions on you know Ben
silencing conservative voices and
whatever making it easier to not get
blocked for you know to be conservative
or whatever right so is that in order to
help stop twitter from blocking him the
day he's no longer president I don't
think that he's thinking ahead in that
way whatsoever I think that these are
basically politically partisan things
that Trump believes now will benefit his
side I don't think he's saying I'm gonna
do this so that Twitter doesn't block me
the day I'm out of I I just don't think
he's I honestly I don't I really don't
huh well maybe he's just incapable of
looking that far forward that that's one
of the reasons why all right thank you
my friend appreciate the phone call
great to hear from you let me pick up
next on our caller from the 772 area
code 772 what's your name and where are
you calling from
hi this mean yes it is hi my name is
Andrew I'm from Jacksonville Florida
hey Andrew what's going on I just wanted
to get your your opinion about Kelly Ann
Connolly and her husband George Conway
and yet dynamic is between them and I
have a theory that she's the one that
wrote that New York Times our bed
resistance piece and that she is
completely on board with George Conway's
critiques of the president it's
interesting you mentioned that so you're
not the first person that has suggested
to me that it's Kelly Ann Conway who
wrote that anonymous critique of the
Trump administration for people who
don't know
Kelly Ann Conway is an advisor to Donald
Trump and very public Trump defender her
husband George Conway is a Republican
who has been one of trumps absolute
biggest critics funding all sorts of
anti Trump ads and I mean it's so so
people are having a hard time
understanding how it is that they're
just living together at home like how is
it possible that these two people could
live together so one of the ideas is
exactly what Andrew is suggesting which
is kept they actually are on the same
page when it comes to Trump and
Kellyanne is just publicly remaining
positive about Trump but privately
actually is on board with George Conway
I don't know the answer but I've
I don't understand how their
relationship works because you know
you've got James Carville and Mary
Matalin Democratic and Republican
strategists who are married but they it
seems as though they've figured out a
way where they're both they're not
really fighting each other in on any
individual race typically Conway and
Conway Kellyanne and George I don't get
how it works and your idea that maybe
behind the scenes they actually both
hate Trump is certainly a possibility
yeah I agree
can I just ask you one more question
yeah what how do you take your coffee
and like what style of coffee do i
almost exclusively I'm drinking espresso
Brit based drinks right now I'm not
really like
drip or filter coffee guy so typically
you know standard six ounce cappuccino
is my go-to certainly in the morning and
then you know I might make a half-caf
now that it's quarantine I'm making
everything at home so I can make a
half-caf iced latte now that it's warmer
in the afternoon or you know could be a
macchiato if I'm feeling crazy maybe
I'll just have an espresso but I am I'm
mostly away from drip coffee and filter
coffee and on espresso okay if you ever
drink a being from Argentina you know I
don't I'm not a big fan of it I'm just
I've never been ever been a big thing
for me okay of course alright thank you
so much great to hear from you a perfect
phone call I would say ladies and
gentlemen let's go next to our caller
from the five four zero area code who's
calling today from five four zero five
four zero please unmute if you have us
muted yes there you go yes who's this
Hey Dude how's it going hey Mitch I was
just calling because I had watched some
of your segments on voting for Joe Biden
ever
Donald Trump and myself I'm kind of
undecided at this point I am not sure
whether I'm not gonna vote or whether
I'm not gonna vote for Jeb lies I was
pulling the lever for but I watched some
of your segments them to me it kind of
feels like for you you're you're pulling
the lever against Trump and for me I
want to be more convinced by by it okay
so let me just pause there because I
want to clarify my position
Yuni voting for Joe Biden is not
exclusively me voting against Trump
there are two people who might be the
next president and I'm choosing the
better option so you know to
characterize it as it's only
vote against Trump or it's a lesser of
two evils it's I don't want to put any
of that sort of frosting on the cake so
to speak it's here are the two choices
and it's so abundantly obvious which is
the better choice that I'm very clear
that I'm gonna vote for the better
choice does that make sense
yeah yeah I apologize I get your
position wrong no problem yeah so I mean
I think you might benefit a little bit
from maybe just talking more about what
those things about by them that you like
I know like general overview and I mean
it's it's very clear that they have very
different positions right all right
maybe just talking about specific
policies might help you I don't know if
the goal of your segments is to just
state your position or to convince
others no this is a very good question
I'm not trying to convince anyone and
I'm not certainly I I've not been
shaming people who don't plan to vote
for Joe Biden what I am if I'm
evangelizing for anything
I'm evangelizing for everybody to be
honest about why they are taking the
action they plan to take so there are
some people on the Left who are kind of
playing coy where they don't like Trump
but they really only focus at least
publicly on criticizing Biden and they
won't actually say they'd rather Trump
to Biden but it's like ultimately that's
what it comes down to so if someone says
listen you know what I was a Bernie
person the reason I'm not voting for Joe
Biden is because given these two choices
I actually believe to hell with it let
Trump get another four years now they
might say that because they want to
punish the DNC they might say it because
maybe they genuinely agree with Trump
more on policy but what I don't want is
people kind of playing coy and playing
this game where they're like yeah yeah
Trump is bad but like Joe Biden in 94
didn't take Social Security cuts off the
table like okay but hold on he's clearly
not running on
now that was 26 years ago do you prefer
Trump or by now if people come away and
they're like I prefer Trump I just I'd
rather Trump be president for the next
four years
beautiful we're now clear on where you
stand but it's the playing coy about
Biden being bad but it's like okay so
would you prefer Trump listen I'm just
pointing out that the DNC screwed
burning okay
do you prefer Trump let's just be honest
about why people are making their voting
decisions that's all I want vote however
you want yeah yeah so I mean I haven't
seen personally like a whole lot of it I
mean I guess you're saying like they're
just pivoting right they're not saying
which they prefer they're not being
upfront they're not being upfront
sometimes about who they actually prefer
and they're not being upfront about
their motives for focusing their
criticism on Biden and and if they were
transparent they're like listen I think
Biden as a center-left candidate is
gonna make us worse off in the long run
which is why I'd rather it be Trump if
it's not going to be burning that's a
position we can now actually talk about
like adults but if we don't really
understand what the goal is if someone
just saying Oh Biden this Biden that
will but then we can't even really talk
about it okay yeah yeah I definitely
appreciate your coverage on all of this
you you've been upfront and honest so
and definitely everything that's going
on now is definitely weighing heavily on
me with the whole protests and Trump's
reaction to it it's really weighing
heavily on that's interesting why did
you consider yourself a never Biden guy
um no I don't think I ever considered
myself and never Biden guy okay a
skeptic never delivery person in 2016 I
just felt very strongly and I was a lot
younger at that point and newer to
politics but I just considered I just
considered that I want to
for someone and not against someone and
by these policies our lackluster to me I
mean matza everybody but to me is there
a particular Biden policy that you
really dislike um yeah he's not for
Medicare for all
so that's huge right right and so is in
your paradigm so Bernie wants Medicare
for all Trump wants this crazy thing
where twenty four million people will
lose coverage Biden is into the idea of
public option plus expanding he said he
likes the idea of expanding Medicare to
sixty plus plus larger subsidies to
people above and beyond the subsidies we
have now so it might give health care to
you know some tens of millions of
additional people does the fact that
bryden's position is so much better than
Trump's way on you at all or does it
only matter that Biden's position is not
Bernie's no it matters to me that even
though Biden's position is better than
Trump's and is good it is undeniably
good all right it is a live thing to
give health care to more people yep it
weighs on me more that his plan leaves
three million more uninsured so I feel
like we should push for Medicare for all
because wait hold on how does by your
saying how does Biden's plan in the net
leave three million more people
uninsured that's you just could agree
that that's not the case
no no not more than current three
million people total will not be covered
by Biden's plan okay I got I gotcha
okay another third he would only insure
ten of those 13 okay but so then that's
making you think you might vote for the
guy who will take it away from twenty
four million more people absolutely okay
all right good good good good
okay all right very good my friend I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much that is all the time I have for
today I apologize I was not able to get
to everybody I will take
again believe you me the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay let me get right into audience
questions we've gotten so many of them
so many things are going on a lot of the
topics are understandable and
predictable and I want to dig right into
them first one David will the protests
and civil unrest be good or bad for
Donald Trump in terms of his approval
rating and his reelection chances in
November listen the answer is very much
like it is on coronavirus Donald Trump's
response to coronavirus was a failed non
response Donald Trump's response on the
civil unrest has been worse than a non
response we have a we have a unrest that
was that started with what was seen as
the brutal unlawful killing by police of
George Floyd and Donald Trump tweeted in
his bunker all weekend okay he was in
his bunker for a few hours
tweeted from the White House all weekend
including from the bunker on Friday
night only to come out on Monday and say
we need more police force we need to
further militarize law enforcement right
so they were the worst possible thing
that he could come out and say but the
trumpet's defended him on coronavirus
and the trumpets will defend him on his
most ly will defend him on his response
to the civil unrest this works in the
short term I don't believe that this
will work in the long term so like with
everything else what matters is how long
is this going to go on take coronavirus
as an example failed response completely
failed response numbers are now starting
to improve states are opening up whether
this will lead to a huge resurgence of
the virus or not we don't know what will
be happening in September October into
the November election we don't yet know
but Trump pretending everything is fine
even when it's not only works for so
long six weeks ago
Trump said no more these press briefings
with doctors I'll do CEO roundtables
little all that stuff and just basically
pretend this is a business situation
rather than a medical situation in the
immediated sort of worked it did get a
lot of trumpets and right-wingers saying
we're back and we're reopening and sort
of disconnected from the realities we
still had 15 people die in a single day
from coronavirus a few days ago so if
that continues
Trump strategy is not going to work
similarly on civil unrest
if protests continue for months through
the summer as coronavirus doesn't go
away and Trump seems to be unable to
control it
deploying the military happens with
increased frequency and it is seen as an
authoritarian move from wannabe baby
dictator Trump a lot of people are going
to react negatively he will still have
the core trumpets that support him no
matter what he does as he said if I
could you know I could shoot people on
Fifth Avenue they'd still vote for me he
could send soldiers to shoot people on
Fifth Avenue and many people would still
vote for Trump but it is not going to
appear to be a strong Trump it is not
going to be a trump that appears in
control even you know earlier this week
the staged photo op propaganda event at
st. John's Church in DC where Trump had
protesters tear gassed and dispersed by
police on horses so he could hold a
Bible up the wrong way like clearly held
the Bible in a way no one who holds a
Bible would ever hold a Bible just to
get that picture yeah some people liked
it and there were some video at its done
of it on Twitter where it's you know
with inspirational music and look at the
great president Trump it's not going to
work for that long
if the protests continue the buck at
some point stops with the president even
Trump said when there were protests
under Barack Obama nothing like what
we're seeing now then it's Obama's
responsibility and of course it's
different rules for Trump we know that
but I do not believe that over the long
term coronavirus continuing is not going
to be good for Trump no matter how he
propagandize is because there are
factual realities on the ground a
continued disastrous economy with 25% of
the labor force that was working before
this started 11 weeks ago unemployed
it's not going to be good for Trump
disastrous GDP numbers coming out in
late August it's not going to be good
for Trump no matter how he propagandize
is in much the same way if the headlines
continue to be things are out of control
yeah you'll have Republicans saying oh
it's all democratic run they'll say
Democrat
run cities that are having a problem
well urban areas are disproportionately
democratic it doesn't you know the
cities that are having problems are
mostly run by Democratic mayors and the
cities that aren't are as well because
that's the way it works we have an urban
rural divide in this country those
talking points will work for a little
while but they are not going to work all
the way through to November if the
unrest continues and Trump seems that to
be the flaccid impotent guy that he is
who can't take control of a situation
who can't be presidential who can't
reduce tensions and rather in flames
them I think it will dramatically
backfire and by the way Joe Biden is no
miracle of progressive values you all
know that but Joe Biden's been giving
some pretty sensible speeches about the
unrest and about coronavirus over the
last 10 days they've widely not been
covered by corporate media for all of
the apoplectic shouting about liberal
corporate media they're covering what
Trump says and does and they're not
covering what the Challenger who could
be president in only what is it now
seven eight months he could be
inaugurated they're not covering what
he's saying and he's making a lot of
sense I mean even a lot of the never
Biden people that watch the show wrote
to me over the last few days saying you
know I'm not I've got to vote for Biden
you know clearly these guys are not the
same the last week has proven that and
Biden's being reasonable imagine if
corporate media actually showed what Joe
Biden has been doing and saying I think
it would be even more disastrous for
Donald Trump David how should we
actually deal with police brutality okay
in this segment I'm not going to argue
about what percentage of cops are good
or bad or try to quantify the degree to
which police brutality and racialized
policing is a problem it is a problem
even listen Rush Limbaugh said things
that were bought you know for Rush
Limbaugh standards conceding that we
have a problem with policing in this
country on The Breakfast Club earlier
this week Kellyanne Conway said it now
Kellyanne Conway also said and Trump is
dealing with it that's a lie I'm not
going to argue about the degree to which
it's a problem it's a problem there
are many issues with policing that need
to be solved it doesn't matter if 92 or
94 percent of police are good or whether
it's 99.1 versus 99.3% we've got a lot
of issues that need to be solved so here
are some ideas from the point of so
there's the legal side and there's the
the behavior side let's talk first about
how police behave we need to be looking
at training and a lot of the
infrastructure that's there so police
training in the United States should be
completely reworked for lack of a better
term if you look at many other countries
officers train much longer before they
are just sent out to be police okay now
there are gonna be arguments about it
costs too much or that I'm telling you
what should be done then we figure out
how to make it happen and by the way we
found six trillion bucks I think we can
find a way to better train police if we
decide we want to do it
Germany as an example trains police much
longer the United States sometimes
you've got like a 12 or 13 week training
program and then you're out there
sometimes it's you know six months or
whatever police training needs to be
longer and a lot more of the training
needs to be more the type of training
that social workers get academic stuff
based on the principles that you would
learn if you were studying for a master
in Social Work because you prevent a lot
of crime what it straight out just you
prevent having to deal with crime then
we'll get to how you how do you deal
with crime you prevent a lot of crime if
you have police that are properly
trained as social workers in addition
there's a lot of stuff that's not
actually criminal or it's marginally
criminalized as misdemeanors that can or
cannot be enforced based on the
discretion of officers we're if you have
officers better trained in de-escalation
you have officers better trained with
some of these soft skills as we might
call them you reduce the number of
interactions that become problematic
number two we need more extensive
psychological and personality testing of
police and we want to just make sure
we're bringing in the right people again
most cops are good some like Trump
admitted on Twitter they're looking for
action there's a sort of bloodlust in
some fraction of police officers those
officers under
stand this and I don't I don't want to
get off-topic here the bad apples the
bad eggs don't just typically do one bad
thing they do a whole bunch so a huge
portion of the over overuse of force
complaints and other bad acts are
concentrated among a small number of
repeat police offenders if we did a
better job of evaluating and psych
testing and personality testing police
we could root out a lot of the problem
by never hiring that small percentage
that wants to get out there and slap
people around and is looking to get the
riot gear and do what we've seen being
done on videos so route them out with it
more psychological and personality
testing there should probably be some
established process for civilian review
of shoot police shootings and uses of
force it can't just be left to police
departments to investigate because we
all know that there are many police
chiefs that are doing this properly we
know that there are internal internal
affairs boards that are operating more
or less okay we should probably have
more civilian involvement in review of
police shootings and uses of force we've
got to demilitarize the militarization
of police forces has been a huge problem
I've talked about that on its own so I
won't delve too much into that and there
should probably be a national database
of bad police actors because it would
prevent two things number one there's a
national database of bad actors people
police officers with a high number of
complaints against them it would prevent
officers from hiding prior complaints by
simply not reporting them when they're
trying to get hired at a new Police
Department because there would be a
national database so reporting to the
database should be mandatory but also if
you're hiring a police officer if you're
not bringing them through police academy
and you're giving them their first
police job it should be a requirement
that police departments have to check
with that central database so that the
police department can't get away with
saying we didn't know we just didn't
know because it would be a requirement
to report complaints to the database and
to look at the database if you are
hiring someone now then you've got
prosecution in terms of prosecution
decisions on prosecution of police
officers
and the prosecution itself meaning the
trials it should be happening
ideally outside the county where the
incidents took place it can be very
difficult to get what we would all call
a fair trial fair to the victims fair to
the officers fair to everybody fair to
the community when a lot of these cases
are being tried inside the jurisdiction
now by the jurist it might be outside of
the town but still in the county and in
a lot of America that's not far enough
that's another thing that should should
be done you've got to try and prosecute
these cases outside
realistically of the county where they
took place some ideas there are many
more I'd love to hear from you
hey David it seems as though it is red
states rather than blue states opening
early from coronavirus and Republicans
rather than Democrats who ignore social
distancing and mask-wearing is it
possible that coronavirus could hand the
election to Biden by killing more
Republicans than Democrats okay I
understand the argument I understand the
argument if you've got a state like
Michigan for example we'll just pick
Michigan and the Democratic voters are
mostly following the guidelines and the
Republican voters are not aren't you
going to get more Republican voters
infected with the virus and thus more
Republican voters will die and it could
flip Michigan from Trump in 2016 to
Biden in 2020 so first of all disclaimer
I hope it's not necessary I don't want
anybody to die I'm not hoping anyone
dies Democrats Republicans it's a
question about math really not a
question about anything else I don't
believe the deaths are numerous nearly
numerous at this point for this to
actually affect the outcome in any state
let's look at an example I mentioned
Michigan in 2016
Trump won Michigan by about 11 thousand
votes right now Michigan has had 5,500
coronavirus deaths even if we imagine
which I'm sure is not the case imagine
that a full 80% of the people who died
in Michigan are Trump voters it's still
not enough to flip an eleven thousand
vote margin and that's a state where the
margin was really really small now
if Michigan ends up with 50,000 deaths
and 80 or 85% of them were trumpets you
might have enough
to flip the state from Trump to Biden
the reality is it's unlikely Michigan is
going to get 10x the deaths we've seen
so far by Election Day
and I think the most important thing
here and again I don't want anybody to
die no one else has to die for us to
realize Trump failed us on coronavirus
in other words if you believe that
coronavirus will affect how people vote
you shouldn't need any more deaths you
shouldn't need anybody else to die from
the virus either for political or
mathematical reasons as we're talking
about for us to know Trump's biggest
test so far has been coronavirus and
he's failed he's being tested on the
civil unrest he's also failing there we
shouldn't need anyone else to die to be
able to say he failed us and he needs to
go last thing on this coronavirus is
also disproportionately affecting poor
people and communities of color those
are communities that disproportionately
vote for Democrats over Republicans so
the older folks the which is a group
that has been better for Trump and for
Republicans they're of course the most
at risk from an age perspective but you
also have communities of color and poor
communities that are disproportionately
affected those are not communities that
are likely to go to trump so I would
even challenge the assertion that that
we started with which is that it is
simply going to be split primarily among
party lines based on following or not
following social distancing guidelines
in the end 130 million people voted in
2016 just to affect 1% of the electorate
you need 1.3 million coronavirus deaths
we are nowhere close to that I hope we
are never anywhere close to that and
certainly there's no indication we would
be anywhere near that in November so it
is unlikely unlikely that the who dies
from coronavirus would be enough to flip
even a single state even a state that
was really close in 2016 by enough votes
to change the outcome if you disagree
with me let me know we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today get instant
access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com
or by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blink is for free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash David Pakman I've
also included the link right underneath
this video